I
think so.
I mean you,
I think it becomes really hard if you,
if you have like,
um,
you know,
stringent rules about what you will and
won't do before you even hear the idea.
Um,
you know,
like a lot of stuff comes to us and
we'll start writing it and usually what
we do is we just,
um,
anything that cracks us up,
you know,
like if we're talking about something,
we all start laughing at it.
That's a really good thing.
And so we try to like,
oh,
why are we all laughing?
This seems like something that could be
good.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
sometimes you start laughing and stuff
and then you start writing it up and
then you're like,
Ooh,
do I really want to do that?
You know,
like,
do I really want to go and shoot that?
Because that's going to be embarrassing.
I mean,
we just sketched this year where I'm a
gay porn star and I get into a car
accident with Aziz and I die.
You know,
he caused the accident so my ghost
haunts him.
So everywhere he goes,
there's this gay porn star,
you know,
like harassing him and doing really
sexual,
horrible things to him.
And,
um,
you know,
we wrote that and we were like,
this is hilarious.
It's gonna be really funny.
And then it comes time to shoot that,
and then you're like,
oh,
great,
now I've got to do this.
So I had to like shave my entire body
and an oil at my body,
and then just being all these really
awkward sexual positions with disease
for long periods of time.
And so,
you know,
sometimes you write stuff and then later
on you look at it,
you're like,
ah,
we shouldn't have,
shouldn't have written that.
That's going to,
it's going to be different.
Okay.